All right, sir. This is the keys. Thank
you very much. I really appreciate it.
Have a wonderful day. All right. No
problem. Hey, you take care. Thanks.
Today, we're going to
duplicate add another key for Kryer
Pacifica 2022. So, this is the new key.
It's an OEM. So, you probably know that
Chrysler and DOT system from 2018 and
up, they need to use the star connector.
You cannot just connect it through the
OBD. So, I have uh these two ADC
2011A. So, uh what we're going to do,
you can see it. We're going to connect
it to one of the green dot. And then
we're going to connect the OBD of the
outel. Sometimes I also do it with the
auto prop. So, I do prefer to use outl.
So, now we're just going to connect the
cable to the OBD. We need to make sure
that we have a an internet. Right now,
it's connected. So, we want to go to the
emo except we're going to go to the
Chrysler. So, if you have a walking key,
you can just leave the key on and do the
other light. If you don't have a working
key, that's not a problem. Just do the
other light. Yep, you already make it.
Now, we're going to read it again. So
establishing right now communication
Voyager is actually a Kryer Voyager no
Pacifica but it's the same system
2022 with we're going to go to control
unit password what we hit again turn off
the ignition and turn on the other D. So
the ignition was turned on we're just
going to turn it off the hardest light
is already on. We're going to hit and
now it's establishing communication.
normally take about a 1 minute, maybe
two to get the pin code. So, it's pretty
fast. So, it's always good to take a
picture of the pin code. After that,
escape. We're going to go into the
killer system. Key learning. Number of
kids. I always like to know how many
keys the car had. Current number of
keys, it's two. Good. Key learning. Make
sure it's off. Where you make sure two
kids, do you want to continue? Yep, you
do.
That's the pin
code. Hold the proximity. So, we're
going to do Okay. Now, we're going to be
ready with the new key. We're just going
to hit the unlock next to the
console. Uh I like kind of do a lot of
clicks. Uh 2 3 seconds of a click until
we're going to hear the unlocked on the
car. That's it.
So, right now, as you can see, current
number three, learn successful. Do you
want to learn an extra key? No, we
don't. So, we're going to hit no. That's
it. Looks good. Let's test some of the
buttons. So, this is an OEM key. As you
see, I used to use an aftermarket keys,
but for this type of car, the
aftermarket is not the best, and I used
to have a few
recalls. So, I do recommend it to do an
OEM key for this specific one. So the
most important thing we're just going
to make sure it's
starting. It's good. Starting looks
good. And uh we need we still need to
cut the the emergency key and we'll be
good to go. All right. Right. So now
we're just going to decode the key. Then
we're going to cut it. Going to go to
Dodge. Let's say Caravan. We don't have
to even though if it's for uh Fiser
Pacifica Voyager, same key. So it's not
have to be the very same one. Key
decode. Confirm. So I'm going to close
it and we're going to hit cut some. Now
we just finished the cut. We're just
going to test it out. Make sure it's
good. All right. Now we're just going to
test it out. Make sure it's good. Looks
good. That's it. It is simple and basic.